And I think you'll agree that you now know a lot.
So you know all of these problems here to be NP complete, which you probably
didn't know before taking this course.
We've also investigated intelligent search trees for vertex cover
and for clique and independent set.
We, unfortunately, were not able to find one for shortest tour, but we know one for 3-SAT.
We talked about pre-processing for vertex cover, and we talked about pre-processing for 3-SAT.
And we showed that vertex cover is fixed parameter tractable using the size of the solution,
and we showed that shortest tour could be fixed parameter tractable as well as 3-SAT
using a measure known as distance from triviality.
We also talked about the constant-factor approximation algorithm for vertex cover.
We showed that there is no such algorithm for clique and independent set.
We had a constant-factor approximation algorithm for shortest tour.
We did not touch upon 3-SAT unfortunately here.
Regarding a PTAS, we know there's non-available for vertex cover.
We also know there is non-available for clique and independent set unless P equals NP.
We mentioned briefly that there might be some available for special cases of shortest tour
but not in the general case also not for 3-SAT.
Then we have the Monte Carlo algorithm for 3-SAT.
We did not go much into Las Vegas algorithms here, but what we then also did
we mentioned that all of these problems here are usually much better solvable in practice
than the worst-case analysis and their NP completeness suggests.
Now compare this table of knowledge
with what the four computer scientists and you knew before taking this course.
And I think you now know a lot about challenging problems but also about the techniques
that you can use to solve them.
So it's of course not all good news, because in general, these problems are hard,
but using this arsenal of techniques here,
you'll usually be able to do something about them in practice as others halve before you,
and I think that can really really really make you stand out among other computer scientists
because not many computer scientists understand the concept of NP completeness alone,
but even those that do once they encounter an NP complete problem, they will tend to just give up
or use some random algorithm, not a randomized one, a random one
where as you now know about these techniques here
and can use them to try and tackle those problems.